hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
continue our coverage of the 2019 a
grand prix the second tournament in
latvia we are in round two so the first
three days we covered round one many of
those games did go into tie breakers and
we are left with eight competitors going
heads up trying to get to the
quarterfinals our competitors today
whites gonna be played by a chop bluff
and blacks gonna be played by in VL
remember this is the best of two series
so regardless of what happens today
these competitors will come back
tomorrow and see what happens then but
we'll go ahead and get started with
today's game tipoff starts with E 4 and
then C 5 getting into the Sicilian
defence Knight to f3 pawn d6 we do see
the exchange in this area the board
fairly common in the Sicilian defense
Knight to f6 Knight c3 pawn a6 pretty
standard for black to play pawn a 6 at
some point here pawn f3 which is not
extremely common this does make it seem
like White's gonna be castling on the
Queen side of the board usually don't
see the pawn chain here on the King side
and early push to f3 that and then
Pawnee 6 just did a video on this
opening not too long ago you can always
check down the website we'll also have a
link in the description below if you're
curious about this specific defense in
the Sicilian offense but we do see white
play Bishop to e3 preparing to castle on
the Queen side of the board and as soon
as we see this now we see pawn to b5
starting to push on the Queen side
anytime you know which side of your
opponent's gonna be on if you're looking
at castle on the other side which right
now it looks like NBL is gonna be
castling to the king side of board you
want to start pushing to the side your
opponent's gonna be cancelling on just
throw everything you can you can protect
these pawns with your minor pieces and
your major pieces but you want to put as
much pressure as possible
Queen to d2 also preparing for the
castle on the Queen side Knight to d7
really do anything here on c6 it would
fall so this prepares for night down to
a c5 and then pawn g4 so automatically
said yeah I'm gonna go ahead and start
pushing on the kingside I've already let
you know I'm gonna castle on the Queen
side so black knows exactly what what's
gonna happen and now it just comes down
to candy execute and defend properly
after white pushes on the King side
black responds by pushing on the Queen
side I do think that blacks should
consider playing pawn to h6 not pushing
forward as soon as he does push then I
can come back here to e2 pretty safe
Square and now this pawn is under attack
by the Queen if you want to hold on to
it it gets a little bit tricky you can't
do it with your rook here on a b8
because of the threat of Knight to c6
and you could even have the in-between
move pawn to g5 forcing the knight to
come over here to h5 and now Knight to
c6 either the rook or the Queen is going
to fall if instead you try to defend it
with your pond
well now you're really starting to push
over here on the Queen side you're
putting all your eggs in the basket of
the King side safety but then pawn g5
the Knights gonna have to come over here
and now this essentially forces the
trade on g3 but after the pottery
captures rook here on h1 is just gonna
be able to tee off on the King side of
the board waiking castle really put both
of his rooks over here and you can see
from black standpoint he does have
either have his bishops involved into
the game he doesn't have a real strong
attack that he can put on this Queen
side so all in all white would have a
pretty strong game from here so after
the pawn comes to b4 knight comes back
here to e2 we see pond h6 just think
it's a little bit late this does open up
the door right away I didn't see double
offtake here which was surprising to me
I thought for sure Queen takes on before
but he plays Knight to f4 which is even
more confusing to me because at some
point pawn to East five makes a lot of
sense he's gonna take one of these
nights I may not want to do it right
away if he looks at this position says
Knight to e6 maybe an exchange
Knight takes attacking the Queen the
Queen moves maybe there's an exchange of
board
I think blacks okay from a
material standpoint he may just not like
this setup instead he decides instead of
pawn to e5 to first play Bishop to b7
after Queen takes on b4 now Queen to c7
this does negate the threat of the Queen
being under attack also starts to attack
this pawn here on c2 defended by the
knight here I think a simple castle on
the Queen side that's exactly what
White's intending and said he brings his
Queen back here to d2 not really sure I
agree with that move as well but now
pawn to e5 Knight comes to f5 would you
sue the pond take here the bishop take
and now that comes down here to e5
Bishop to e2 Queen down to c7 and then
eventually castle on the Queen side so
as you're looking at these there's some
interesting moves in my opinion from
white specifically as far as how he's
attack I think MV Ella's put him in
position to actually have a really solid
game up some material but white hasn't
done all the moves that I would expect
him to do and remember because we are in
round 2 this is not a blitz game this is
not rapid we are back to classical where
you essentially are getting 2 hours in
the game and get the first 90 minutes in
the first 40 moves then you get an
additional time added on after that and
you're getting 30 seconds added each so
they have plenty of time to think about
these moves she's a little surprising
for each of the players in some of their
decision process and from there we have
castle on the Queen side another move
that was not quite expecting when he
looks at I think he realizes just so
much was building up on the Kings side
he couldn't really stop all of it so
he's putting all of his basket are out
all of his eggs in the basket of
defending over here attacking being the
best defense for him so really it comes
down to Cain he executes King to a b1
pawn to g6 attacking the knight Knight
comes back here to e3 Bishop e7 and then
pawn C Ford another interesting move in
my opinion from Topal off this opens up
the door for some attacking
lines against the King here on b1 one of
those attacking lines is for the bishop
to eventually come here to e4 now
there's one defender on that and that is
the pawn here on f3 black could ride
away played Knight takes on e4 pawn
recaptures the bishop takes this is
forking the rook here on h1 so if the
King moves boom the bishop comes down
here and takes on h1
after the rook takes Bishop we can come
down here to g5 if he wants to but that
was a good exchange from black now in
the game he decides to first play King
to b8 rook to c1 add another defender on
this pawn since both the Knights and the
Queen are attacking it but this point we
see black come down and take here and
then after the exchange the rook is
gonna fall on h1 rook recaptures on h1
Bishop to g5 Knight up here to d5
attacking the Queen Bishop first takes
here on f4 sighs you can take my queen
I'll take your queen Queen takes here on
f4 and then Queen over here to e7 one
thing we want to look at is if we come
back here after Knight to d5 attacking
the Queen but I cannot take here on c4
and say yeah I'm up on a material after
this exchange you take my queen I'll
take your queen because of Queens to d4
so if you're looking at curious why he
didn't play that that's exactly why so
instead he decided to play the Bishop to
f4 after the Queen to a7 rook to c1 just
bring it back to the only side of the
board that matters right now that is the
Queen side rook to e8 so black he has
the rook pair here he wants to control
the center of the board with that pawn
to a three-night here to c6 Bishop f3
just trying to control these lights go
diagonals and cut off some of the
critical squares that black could bring
his King to pawn attacks the Queen Queen
comes back here to g3 centralizing the
Queen here on a c5 Bishop back to h1 and
then rook down to e2 you always want you
want to get your rooks to the second
rank if you're black if you're white you
want to get
here to the seventh ranked so black
definitely playing the aggressor he's
been playing defense for a while now but
II - really that first mover he says I'm
I start to attack all your pieces behind
enemy lines Knight to c3 so why it's
kind of fading back into defense mode
here rook to e3 attacking both the
knight and the Queen Queen comes back
here to g2 rook to c8 here and then
Knight up to a C Phi or d5 that's a
great outpost attacking the rook right
here the rook comes to b3
I came to a2 attacking the rook rook
comes back to a b7 so no longer
attacking but doesn't have a pretty
strong defense here in front of his king
y continues with pawn to b3 a five-night
to a c3 Queen down III attacking the
rook rook comes up here to see to just
come a little bit closer there is an
exchange on the board and then we see
rook to e7 any exchanges I think is
gonna favor black the rooks just
dominate in the endgame when you start
to open up the board states and the pond
start to come off the board the rooks
just control so much of the game and
it's much easier to get the rooks behind
ponds push those pawns forward and
promote you can't really control all of
the squares that they push on with one
minor piece whether that is a knight or
a bishop they can help along the journey
but rooks do a much better job rook to
d6 attacking some of these backward
pawns a rook to the eights here we do
see an exchange on the board and then
Bishop to e4 pawn h5 says yeah I'll go
and exchange material right here I'll
even give up someone's here right here
and why is that because after the rook
to f7 can easily swing back here to F to
check gobble up some material right here
and this is where it comes down to
execution in the
in game pun to a g4 and it's very
difficult for white to really hold on to
all the material the King needs to stay
over here on the Queen side of the board
to hold on to these ponds but he also
wants to get his king over here to the
king side because he recognizes the
pressure that he's under by this pawn
and this rook it's a tough decision at
the end the Daito blob decides to go and
start bringing his King involved into
the game and now let's get this night
involved King to d1 and now Knight to d4
getting ready to start gobbling up
material right here which is exactly
what toe blob does not want to happen he
just doesn't have too many other choices
Knight to d4 Knight to g3 now the King
gets involved into the game he can
always just use just as some in between
moves if there's ever a board state
where he's like a knight sure I don't
want to move with peace because it may
not be good for me you can just get his
King involved into the game wait for his
opponents and make a mistake
Bishop to e4 Knight down here to e r to
f3 any time this Bishop takes or any
other piece takes the pawn can just take
right here and this King can't come up
to the second rank the rook here on h2
it can swing back and forth can just
really negate where the king can move to
pawn to c5 Knight down to d2 attacking
the bishop King comes over here to g1
that's fine rook to h3 this is an
outpost for the rook which we typically
don't go over too much but it cannot be
taken King here - G - that's fine Knight
takes and from here it's just pretty
much game over yes the knight can take
but then the rook can just gobble up all
material a rook versus a night in game
is always going to end up favoring the
side with the rook and there's no way
for this pawn tits are this night to
take all the ponds very easy for the
rook to take and then eventually end up
with either a passed pawn and promote to
a queen or just be able to ended the
game with his rook so with the win here
as the black pieces NBO is one step
closer to the semi-finals all he needs
is a draw in the next game and he will
move on to the round of four players
would be one step away from the
championship so congratulations to MVL
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and I'll see you guys tomorrow in
a game number two or round number two
thanks for watching